bonjour je suis tel c'est ensemble que
nous allons découvrir l'histoire du
soulier
[Musique]
dans histoire de souliers nous allons
explorer l'univers de la chaussure
féminine de l'escarpin la ballerine en
passant par la chaussure compenser les
bottines les bottes les mary jane
les cuissardes et toutes les autres
mais comme les et bette midler donné une
fille des chaussures correct et elle
peut conquérir le monde
dans histoire de souligner je vous dirai
tout sur cette arme de destruction et de
séduction massive les femmes et leurs
chaussures où la relation la plus
fusionnel qui soit avec un accessoire
votre vie ne sera joué car la quête du
graal trouver la chaussure parfait en
somme ou sur son histoire et les
infinies possibilités offertes à
montjean aujourd'hui dans l'histoire de
souliers la basket et la chaussure
sportswear d'où viennent d'elles comment
les porter des professionnels de la mode
et de la confection de chaussures vous
expliqueront son histoire saviez vous
par exemple que cette chaussure doit
beaucoup au développement de l'industrie
pneumatique
vous découvrirez ensuite quelles sont
les tendances du moment nos
professionnels vous aiguilleront avec
leurs conseils shopping
ils vous apprendront également ce qu'il
faut éviter à tout prix
enfin nous vous présenterons des modèles
de baskets complètement extravagantes
n'avait probablement jamais eu et qui
ont fait fureur dans les milieux de la
haute couture et du design mais tout
d'abord allons voir ce que vous en
pensez
[Musique]
paris c'est au coeur de la capitale de
la mode que nous sommes allés enquêter
pour savoir ce que vous pensiez de la
basket
alors mesdames votre avis les baskets
genre
pour aller à l'école
tout ça parce que c'est
ces pass partout c'est confortable et
puis si j'ai envie de mettre une petite
touche un peu plus film
très des ballerines quand même mais très
rarement des talons sont pas très classe
[Rires]
ça pue confort en dvd basket pour
marcher pendant que de m
pour le combat elle reflète un état
d'esprit décontractée une nonchalance
plus ou moins maîtrisés et surtout elle
symbolise la mode de la rue
alors qu'on les aime ou qu'on les
déteste les baskets font partie de notre
vie
voyons comment elles sont nées les
modèles historiques et comment les
porter
[Musique]
qu'est ce que la chaussure sportswear
vous évoque alors là je pense qu'on a
beaucoup de choses à dire ça ça me
faisait mal
ouais ça ça nous évoque je suis une
grande fan et juliette aussi d'anciennes
éditions qui appartenait surtout aux
basketteurs et voilà ça arrive au pied
des jeunes femmes et on est vraiment
super contente et y être créatrice aussi
qui s'appelle isabelle marant qui a
remis vraiment les baskets aux chaudes
au goût du jour
et là pour le coup on parle de talent
compenser à l'intérieur de la chaussure
donc on a après son maître en talons
mais en basket en plus elles sont
complètement à vienne d'ailleurs ses
baskets et mais on les adore on en a
chacune une paire et on est hyper bien
dedans et c'est génial
voilà comment on a le confort de la base
et en même temps on a la posture et
l'élégance du rayon voilà c'est
absolument parfait et les baskets en
toile traditionnel qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
moi ça n'inspire pas trop les baskets en
toile traditionnels à moins que converse
ou ou vans et envie de me sortir une
édition en toile de jouy
s'il ya peu de chances que ça vous
inspire la loi je sais pas si cet empire
mans glitter sinon c'est tout non c'est
vrai que c'est pas très oui bon alors
pourquoi elle pour aller courir mais
voilà tout ce que ça m'évoque
[Musique]
m
c'est la mode américaine c'est la mode
peut-être de new york où toutes les
toutes les femmes vont travailler en
basket et se change au bureau et
enfilent leurs escarpins ou leurs bottes
voilà et donc c'est arrivé en europe et
maintenant toutes les femmes ont eu une
paire de baskets chic mode et raffinée
voilà qui encore une fois est
incontournable dans la garde-robe d'une
femme
la basket qu'on pensait peut-être porté
par toutes les femmes je répète par
toutes les femmes pourquoi parce que à
l'intérieur il ya donc cette cale qui
démultiplierait la cambrure et quand on
marche
eh bien on est vraiment sur coussin
d'air et tout le monde peut la porter à
tel point que maintenant on a des formes
de basket qui sont qui n'ont plus de
rapport avec la basket entre guillemets
et c'est un phénomène maintenant de
ville
donc tout le monde à sa paire de baskets
enfin la personne qui a envie d'être
confortable et sexy voilà pour faire du
shopping par exemple
[Musique]
bien avant l'invention de la basket les
indiens du brésil protéger déjà leur
pied avec la résine issus de l'arbre à
caoutchouc
le latex et qui dit chaussures de sport
dit forcément caoutchouc
bien que cette matière et ses
découvertes dès le xvème siècle il
fallut attendre le milieu du xixème
siècle pour qu'un certain charles
goodyear invente le procédé de
vulcanisation pour que la semelle en
caoutchouc apparaissent
[Musique]
la première chaussure de sport fut
fabriqué aux états unis en 1868
dès lors le basket furent portés par les
sportifs et quelques marques
commencèrent à voir le jour reebok en
1890 pour les chaussures de course et la
légendaire converse en 1908 destiné aux
basketteurs
c'est grâce à chuck lorre un célèbre
basketteur que les converse all star
deviendront populaire par la suite ce
modèle pris la signature du nom du
fameux basketteur
[Musique]
en 1948 adidas et puma apparu et c'est
dans les années 50 que les baskets
deviennent de vraies chaussures de ville
grâce notamment à l'acteur james dean et
au converse qu'il portait lors de ses
apparitions à l'écran en 1979 c'est la
marque nike qui révolutionna l'univers
de la basket par un concept innovant la
basket sur coussin d'air
[Musique]
depuis les années 80 et 90 les baskets
sont présentes dans la botte de tous les
jours et représente est l'essence même
du streetwear
c'est au début des années 2010 qu'une
nouvelle grande tendance est apparue
grâce à une créatrice française qui
cartonne isabel marant et ses fameuses
baskets à talons qui sont devenus une
pièce indispensable pour toutes les
modeuses
[Musique]
pour expliquer pourquoi le basket peut
maintenant être vu sur un tapis rouge au
pied d'une grande vedette
je pense qu'il ya deux raisons une c'est
que la grande talons août ça fait mal il
y a quelque chose devait à l'ansa et je
pense que l'autre raison c'est que les
designers qui tienne la route sont mis à
faire des baskets
donc il y a tout le monde puis à l'élu
but mais tout le monde fait des baskets
aujourd'hui c'est quand même arrivé par
l'homme donc en fait chez nous c'est
arrivé par ses baskets très travaillée
route est souvent doré dans des matières
des couleurs et ce à ses côtés il basket
même moi je suis capable de il y à
quelques baskets homme qui me fait
fantasmer donc il ya une basket à ce
moment avec une totale dans des couleurs
très canadienne et quand je regarde ça
oui il ya quelque chose de très
intelligent dans ce produit de baskets
compensées peuvent être facilement porté
par toutes les femmes donc très
facilement le compenser c'est
pragmatique le basket qu'on pensait à ce
que c'est le compenser le plus joli à
mon avis non mais on vendre dans le
subjectif et si on veut avoir en fait
qu'est-ce que ça en même pas contre qui
est intéressant c'est que ça amène une
vraie hauteur tance affine la jambe
d'une certain nombre de filles qui
qu'ils ont besoin tout en restant de
cajou elle donc c'est le côté trop près
quelque part qui est intéressante en ce
produit
qu'est ce que la basket vous évoque
alors la basket vont aller poser de
questions il ya deux trois ans ça
m'aurait fait penser au sport au tennis
au basket mais pas vraiment à une
chaussure féminine et ce qui se passe
depuis deux ou trois ans et puis nous
vraiment voilà on l'a ressentie depuis
le départ c'est qu'aujourd'hui une vraie
nouveauté c'est qu'on te porter des
baskets compensées
donc tout est justement là on arrive à
avoir quelque chose de féminin avec
vraiment une hauteur de talons avec un
compenser intérieur et en même temps
quelque chose de très sport donc
aujourd'hui la basket il ya plusieurs
styles plusieurs formes
on a soit c'est vrai le compenser
intérieur donc le compenser intérieur où
finalement on le voit pas et on a aussi
donc l'oim compenser parfois un petit
peu plus visible mais aujourd'hui c'est
la tendance la plus forte qui est portée
à la fois par des ados par des femmes
c'est aujourd'hui un modèle qui est
extrêmement important la deuxième chose
dans la basket c'est qu'on oublie un
petit peu la sage au détriment du crash
donc c'est un produit il ya deux trois
ans
franchement on aurait dit ça ya deux
trois ans on aurait mis du temps avant
de avant le porter aujourd'hui tout le
monde se les arrachent on arrive
vraiment être dans la tendance avec des
produits qui soient confortables
vraiment on peut associer on peut
s'amuser on peut s'associer des matières
des couleurs
donc c'est vraiment un produit très
agréable à travailler et puis moi y'a
juste à regarder dans la rue
aujourd'hui peut-être une femme sur deux
qui à sa paire de baskets compensées
donc c'est un produit qu'on en tout cas
nous on met beaucoup en avant et je
pense que c'est le début aussi ça fait
que depuis vraiment une saison d'hiver
une saison d'été et ça va encore faut-il
donc là baskets compensées et la
chaussure du moment we say die chose
c'est là il touche parce que on la voit
pour l'instant voilà pas tout à fait sûr
sur tout le monde c'est un produit on
est un impôt début on est content on a
été aussi précurseur dans ce dans cette
histoire de chaussures compensées donc
voilà aujourd'hui ça commence vraiment à
se démocratiser on commence vraiment les
mois ou
[Musique]
la route
êtes vous bien dans vos baskets
parmi les chaussures qui font la mode de
tous les jours il y à la chaussure de
sport qu'elle soit réellement fait pour
aller transpirer battre le pavé pour que
la basket soit juste une question de
style
les baskets font partie de notre
quotidien on a toutes et tous une ou
plusieurs paires de chaussures de sport
et elles sont souvent liés à notre mode
de vie ou à notre humeur même si on se
doute bien que la basket ne fait pas
nécessairement partie des modèles de
prédilection des créateurs de haute
couture et des designers puisque
chaussures sportives et facilement
abordable nous avons quand même plus
d'écouter quelques modèles qui
exploitent les possibilités de création
qui lui sont propres et c'est le plus
souvent sur un mode tape à l'oeil que la
réinvention de la basket se manifeste
parmi les modèles de chaussures
sportswear des grandes marques qui ont
voulu par moment sortir des sentiers
battus on retrouve par exemple chez
adidas une basket à l intégrer ainsi que
c'est impressionnant modèle à ailes de
papillon amovible qui se lassent sur le
côté de la chaussure les inventions
signé jeremy scott
toujours dans un style original et peu
discret reebok nous présente des baskets
avec un imprimé ludique représentant le
plateau du célèbre jeu de société
monopoly
par ailleurs la fameuse marque converse
a créé une collection de mes extensions
qui prolonge la chaussure en un pantalon
entier pour celles d'entre vous qui
seraient tentés d'en mettre plein la vue
à tout le monde avec des modèles aussi
audacieux désolé mais ils ne sont pas en
production
ils purent créer simplement à l'occasion
d'un défilé dans la section haute
couture chanel propose un modèle de
sneakers montantes et ajouré rappelant
la lente elle
ainsi que d'autres modèles creepers avec
cette fois une semelle épaisse compenser
christian louboutin quant à lui toujours
haute en couleurs a réalisé une basket
montante devrait entièrement cloutés
pour un étai bling-bling maximale du
côté de chez ann demeulemeester on
retrouve une basket d'un style assez
stricts en dégradé du beige au noir avec
fermeture éclair et se mêlent en dents
de scie enfin comme nous les avons
évoqué plusieurs fois dans l'émission
pour si les fameuses baskets à talons
compensés de la créatrice isabel marant
décliné en plusieurs couleurs
[Musique]
la basket provence et ça pour moi c'est
véritablement une révolution la basket
font penser deux villes alors je n'ai
pas les lire avec une copine et je vois
pas l'intégrer parce que pour moi les
baskets school et je vois pas pourquoi
mais légalement à des basques à je
comprends pas l'intérêt
je trouve pas ça machin les gens
n'achèteront pas parce que je vois les
images d'un hostile je suis content
qu'un modèle à bord a priori si les
priori de bon goût s'ils sont tous
portés avec des lattes mauguio
[Musique]
qui a raison
une robe
soit reconnue
c'est la journée sans débat
le contenu du jour pour l'achat sur un
peu sportswear donc nous affectionnons
tout particulièrement les nouvelles
baskets à talons donc notre petit
conseil c'est de les choisir bien les
essayer mais choisir hyper confortable
qu'on soit bien dedans qu'on soit comme
des chaussons parce que c'est quand même
l'objectif de la basket ses pouvoirs
trotter toute la journée vraiment tenir
dans des conditions difficiles mais tout
en étant en talons donc ça nous permet
d'avoir la posture du talon et le
confort de la basket
moi je milite pour le retour du doré et
de l'argenté sur la chaussure sportswear
voilà je trouve que c'est une chaussure
qui doit rester hyper bling bling qui va
jouer complètement décalé complètement
second degré qu'on va à sortir à une
tenue du coup plutôt sobre plus tôt en
jean un short en jean un slim noir un
short noir et voilà rester vraiment dans
des tenues très très sobre avec une
chaussure avec une grosse basket à iter
bling bling que moi je j'affectionne
tout particulièrement en doré et en
argenté
conseils shopping pour la chaussure
sportswear et bien on peut la porter
comme on veut c'est à la carte
les modèles pourrait tendance
aujourd'hui c'est bien évidemment la
baskets compensées raffinée très
féminine mais aussi avoir une ou deux
paires de ballerines ça ils feront à vos
rides et sans compter les plages est en
plein été donc on s'échappe insi
industrie tout du sportswear c'est si un
produit réservé à quelqu'un qui a des
grandes jambes fines
si c'est le cas pourquoi pas avec une
short ou même une jupe mais pour nous
les mortels normal je dirais c'est à une
idée alors pour choisir son modèle
sportswear je dirais que tout ce qui
ressemble à quelque chose dans laquelle
on devra corps et orale à bois de
boulogne c'est vraiment à éviter donc si
si on achète une modèle sportswear c'est
mieux de prendre quelque chose qui est
un peu aboutie qui qui est un peu décoré
mais moi personnellement je préfère
juste être couverts si vraiment il faut
que je suis en sportive à moi je préfère
les trucs intemporel comporte depuis des
décennies
ce que je vois un sport qui m'intéresse
donc là la côte et street qui
m'intéresse et qui est montante seller
street qui sont déguisés en citadine
donc c'est les baskets qui sont
travaillés avait écrit à qui on trouve
normalement sur une richesse une derbi
il y a des perforations et en première
vue on aurait pu dire que watson a fait
cette basket mais non c'est une basket
c'est du street
et ça c'est une tendance qui me plaisent
quel est votre conseil look pour la
basket
bon là mais avec avec un jean c'est un
slim
j'aimerais plutôt avec un stream ce qui
me plaît mois dans la basket c'est
vraiment le décalage entre finalement
une chaussure qui est assez lourde entre
guillemets parce qu'il ya quand même des
mélanges de couleurs de matières et puis
en même temps voilà la finesse du
produit avec un avec un slim moi je l'aï
jamais comme ça puis ça se porte tout le
temps finalement ça peut avoir au départ
un côté un petit peu plus sport mais si
on décide de la prendre
noir en cuir noir alain côté déjà un
petit peu plus porsche et qu'on va dire
donc récapitulons pour être au top de la
tendance avec nos baskets mesdames aux
et les baskets à talons
car elles ont le double avantage du
confort et de la posture élevé le gling
gling que vous soyez plutôt dorures
plutôt strass ou les deux surtout ne
vous privez pas la tendance est à
l'audacieux et comme on vous le dit
souvent tenues sobres chaussures
rock'n'roll ou tenue rock n roll
chaussures sobre les jeans slim tout en
simplicité et en décontraction
il assure une neutralité qui sublimera
vraies chaussures pour conclure sur la
chaussure sportswear même si elle trouve
son origine dans le milieu du sport la
basket s'est parfaitement adapté à nos
modes de vie urbains indispensable pour
nos activités sportives
cette chaussures décontractées se porte
surtout pour une question de confort et
d'attitudes le choix proposé par les
créateurs est si riche que chaque femme
peut trouver basket à son pied
quel que soit son style vestimentaire un
conseil très simple choisissez des
baskets en toile et associer les as du
de nîmes un tee shirt blanc et une veste
de blazer look de parisienne chic
garantie et si vous vous sentez l'âme
d'une fashionista opté pour des baskets
à talons intégré vous gagnerez de la
hauteur affine revo jambes tout en étant
au coeur de la tendance actuelle à très
bientôt pour la suite d'histoires de
souliers
[Musique]
oui